okay let's go to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
and see what's on people's minds very
very big week of news we will start with
our caller from the four to five area
code caller from four to five who's this
where are you calling from hi this is
justice I'm calling from Seattle go
ahead just if what's on your mind yes I
have a question so on so after taunt the
whole fiasco with um in like doing that
the big thing in front of stuff in the
White House and and like hinting at
calling it a national emergency do you
think I was going to do things like this
for other policies or do you think this
is just the border wall thing because it
was just such a sorry um important thing
to his fan base well I think that it
depends on the success of it right so if
I'm hopeful that this bogus fake crisis
address that Donald Trump did on Tuesday
night I'm hopeful that it is seen as a
turning point in the Trump presidency
and a major major mistake because it was
just a disastrous idea it didn't warrant
a national primetime address and
particularly if it doesn't help Trump
get money for the wall he may think
twice I mean I know that he's not
exactly the most logical thinker but he
may think twice about trying to do it
again if this succeeds if he ends up
getting funding for the wall or it
functions to shift blame for the
shutdown to Democrats or whatever then I
think yes he's liable to use it
particularly if he gets more desperate
as we get closer to the 2020 election
I feel like totally with me I try
complying with what he wants and this
kind of creating work to business and
more hostility I feel like that almost
benefits him and so I would like kind of
seeing him doing it again even if it
wasn't successful yes he will definitely
do it again if it's successful and he
still might even if it's not he still
might no no I'm agreeing with you I'm
saying he if it works he'll we can count
on it even if it doesn't work he may
still have seen it as useful in some way
and might do it again yeah so I think
you're spot-on
yeah just really well but anyway thanks
all right thank you for the call
appreciate that